foreign
[Music]
our soil is dying and we as a generation
have a responsibility to save it for our
future Generations
do you know that the soil is the largest
living system on the Earth
95 percent of the food that we eat
directly or indirectly comes from the
soil
the health of the soil hence is very
important for the health of our species
but 52 percent of the soil around the
world has already degraded
we're losing one football field every
second
by 2045 the research says if we go on
like this
there will be 9.2 billion people in the
world and 40 percent lesser food
and that is when the guys with the
biggest guns will take it all
this is not the future that we want for
our children
the present itself is showing the signs
the developed countries are talking
about climate change global warming and
whatnot
the underdeveloped and the developing
countries are suffering because of the
floods
the droughts
the unpredictable rain and snow patterns
landslides and more
all of this is hinged around
1 billion
bill of carbon dioxide and the
greenhouse gas emissions that we do
every year
in the name of
existence
industrialization
or growth
growth that is coupled with the
ah the growth that is coupled with the
migration of people from rural settings
into the urban settings straining the
cities and then eventually causing
unrest now the United Nations knows all
of this and in cop 27 they finally
declared
that there is a possible solution which
is scalable
reliable and long term
they call it
the health of
soil
and the solution is right under our feet
now let me tell you what is healthy soil
the difference between dirt and soil is
the organic content so if you remove the
organic content from the soil it becomes
dirt and for the soil to be called
healthy we need to have three to six
percent organic content in it
as we are standing now the dirt part of
it the normal agricultural soils have
gone down to about 0.5 to 1.5 percent
organic content
a handful of healthy soil has eight
billion microorganisms more than all of
us on the planet
a handful
and these microorganisms are very
important to build up the closed loop
carbon Cycles which were very important
for our life actually to exist
now the healthy soil is also
has the capacity to basically hold
carbon more than the plants in the
atmosphere put together
and this sequestered carbon into the
soil is very important for the nutrient
value of the food and also to take away
the carbon from the atmosphere
the healthy soil is also the largest
water reservoir
because it's loose and it's permeable
the water that drops on it gets absorbed
the soil holds the water stores the
water and provides it back to the plants
and the trees when they require it
the healthy soil will also improve the
yields and the nutrient value of the
foods that we eat there but
what exactly is happening you know the
the aware and the awakened Farmers have
actually gone down to regenerate a
farming regenerative farming is all
about
using the the cash rotating the cash
crops keeping the cover crops
integrating the livestock within the
Farms using less pesticides and
chemicals and increa increasing the
biodiversity of the soil now Sikkim is a
very small state in India and they
declared in 2003 after the Green
Revolution of India was booming they
declared in 2003 that they wanted to go
completely organic and last year they
declared themselves as a completely
organic State now the governments are
making efforts to do that but the
question but before that maybe what I
can share with you is that a lot of us
in this room here are pretty
detached to this problem because we live
in urban settings our food comes from
the supermarket
are air-conditioned temperature Define
what the global warming is if it's warm
outside we can cool it off inside and we
literally get very tone deaf to the
crying Planet but one thing that's
common between these suffering people
and US my friends is that in the next 30
to 40 years we will be gone from the
planet left will be our children
who will then be thinking that what were
we thinking at this point of time and
spoiling the planet
so the next question I've been asked
during the last couple of days with a
lot of friends who have spoken about
safe soil is what can we do as
individuals
uh while the governments are looking at
the environmental changes and the
environmental issues we as individuals
can look at Civic issues
reduce
the use of the material as much as we
can I will not get into the vegan versus
the vegetarian versus the meat eaters
debate that's a sensitive one but let me
tell you a fact for one calorie of red
meat that we eat we need to produce
seven calories of livestock feed and
that's a lot of pla that's a lot of load
we put on the planet to produce
tender rare or well done steaks
we can be reusing Recycling and
rethinking of what we can actually use
as a collective
what we can do is as part of Democratic
Society we can be the worst we can be
the voice in the vote for the soil
um the QR code talks about a movement
called the conscious planet and the save
the soil movement that I'm kind of
promoting here please click onto the QR
code and get on right onto the uh to the
movement basically we can
be the Earth buddies We As Leaders
l-e-a-d-e-r-s can be the voice because
when we speak the Stanford graduates
speak people stand and listen so join in
the movement become the voice Jan for
instance Thanks Jen is a CEO of an
organization in the Philippines she was
an early mover with me and she joined me
in promoting it in her in her
organization
so there are various ways that we as
Leaders can get on with this movement
now I am guilty as charged I traveled
half the globe improve increase my
carbon footprint to be here with you
guys while I could have done it on a
zoom call
and that's what one of my friends
suggested when I was telling him that
I'm going to do this but let me tell you
I am also consciously trying to increase
my carbon handprint and planting trees
and making sure that I reduce my usage
of a lot of other stuff and trying to
get more green I'm a vegetarian by
choice and that makes me one of those
who is only consuming one calorie of it
there but for me coming down here
friends was an investment that I made
for the fact that this cause is
important for my children's mere
existence it's important for the
children next doors
the children of my city the children of
the planet probably your loved ones and
yours
and this is a cause that I would request
all of you to lean in because we I think
have extracted enough from the planet
it is time for us to give back because
the planet
is not a legacy that we took from our
parents it is something that we borrowed
from an unborn child
and the solution is right under our feet
and I would say
it's in our hands
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]